like yeah you can kind of get their
personality a little bit more also i'm
sorry i'm sorry if any any sporting game
i trash talks like
hopefully but i trash talk and i will
trash talk you were trash talking 15
year old
okay i
okay so we went so a couple of weeks ago
right me and her went down to my regular
sports center to play basketball and
then there was like a couple of guys
there where we played and stuff like
let me jump in i was like i'll i'll take
her with my on my team and stuff like
that and she was just like working in
the post like that right
i just kept giving her the ball and
she's just posting them up and just
laying there posing them up and laying
i'm like what the [ __ ] what is going on
and then i think the kids i think they
are taking they were actually not they
were in college they were like 17 18
years
old i think they were taken back because
like i'm pretty strong and most guys
like don't really expect that yeah and
so no i was i'm i had them sealed they
couldn't do that
it was like all jokes aside there is a
video called um what was the youtube
channel i think it's like on uh honcho
nation the youtube channel or something
like that so yeah go check it out
they cut out no they cut out they cut
out everything they only put it when we
were like
like
no every every missed shot they like put
all together and i'm like did you not
you missed the part where i i bullied
you
like the funny thing is yeah every
single time ever since then yeah they
every time they i come in to play they
don't they don't they
[Music]
um okay there's one more super chat
question from mgtow by logic again guys
all super chats are towards a new camera
so we can get multiple angles in here
really appreciate it
um okay so at what point after a woman
meets a man does she owe him honestly
her thoughts and feelings about him
like i wouldn't say like oh oh my god i
had a guy ask me this on the first date
he's like so what do you think of me i'm
like
oh my god
no i was like
i feel like no one should be answering
those type of questions because like you
can't like from from the first date when
you meet you can't really
this is awesome
because you don't know that you don't
know them you
you don't know them at all like you
don't owe them an explanation of what
like it's it's the same as asking like
what are we the first week that you've
been you've seen each other it's like
it's it's a better question to ask is
like is there a second day because then
you're not asking okay like what do you
want like you're showing interest like
do you want a second day like that does
sorry i asked you to read that question
again
i'm gonna hear it
questions
yeah the question let me scroll up um at
what point after a woman meets a man
does she owe him honesty in her thoughts
and feelings about him
yeah did you okay i think um
because like every like
relationship or situation i guess
kind of rolls at different timings
and i would say like why would you want
to force someone to tell you how they
feel like shouldn't they be the one to
open up to you instead of like you know
tell me how do you feel about me like
wouldn't you rather have them like have
feelings for you and just be like
wanting to tell you you know i feel like
a lot of guys don't like listen to the
signs
where it's like
i don't think my time
i think i think they just need like you
to full-on just be like i like you
men don't actually like to read into
things i think women do
but like men choose not to so or
just don't know how to yeah i've
interpreted that question in a very
different way okay i interpret it as in
like if you just met someone in the
first it would come back to the first
scenario
like should you tell him immediately or
or at some point after the date mm-hmm
well i'm not feeling you listen we're
not doing this again rather than deep
feelings i think you guys went for a
emotional deal oh
that's what i've read as well
so like during the day like okay let's
say we're on a date like during the day
we're like i'm gonna go now because i'm
not feeling the day like i feel like
that would be like really i don't know
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no you don't see that you don't see
that right there buddy i think the
question is more like well after you had
a date
like when someone's like what when okay
do you keep talking and stringing it
along or she should be honestly actually
you know that we're good lovely meeting
you and but i don't want to see you
again i think it's good courtesy to like
um after the date to write to them and
tell them okay i enjoyed the day or i
didn't enjoy the letter yeah like okay
you get yourself
so just like send them a message i'm
like oh i enjoy the day i would like to
have a second day i enjoyed the date but
i don't think we'll have a second date
that's basically the bare minimum but
what house you know i think again my
operation it might be different one to
do with subjects but how
i don't like a guy i'd just text him
right out like after him
yeah just like get this done
i just let them know the next time they
ask me or if they even do ask me you
know
i just i don't know i'm
i'm very non-confrontational so i know
what you mean i feel like it's quite
difficult as a woman to kind of
i don't know yeah to like break things
off because men will make it the memo
make it easier they're like oh like i
don't want to see you again like why i'm
like but
isn't this enough
i don't want to get more feedback so you
said something three months ago so you
um don't you said something i'm going to
challenge it it's not that men don't
want to see signs and read signs we're
not as good at reading inside and seeing
signs yeah that's right it's not we're
not that we're not we don't we don't
want you so we're not as good as it as
you are so you might be putting signals
out but we just miss them i'm sure yeah
has been an example would have liked a
guy seen a guy liked him and you think
you did the most to get his attention he
ain't [ __ ] seeing it he's not he's
not yeah he's like oblivious to it
sometimes it could be we
have to be sometimes to be quite obvious
and quite blatant with us because we're
not picking we don't get a subtlety
sometimes
yeah but i do feel like
i mean like someone can
i mean i think like just men are they're
just naturally more like logical and
they don't do the
oh like what does this mean what does
this mean does this mean something like
we can do a lot of things but pick up on
like little hints they don't yeah they
don't do the overthinking that we kind
of do like we think like oh everything
like kind of not everything but like you
know yeah you're like you're looking at
the details i think women really look at
the details and then kind of look at the
general picture what something means so
for example you've got a partner right
maybe you've been if you're in a way of
your partner and like walked a room with
like women and you've like seen them or
got a vibe from them that they're
watching your young man and you're like
she's a
no we're just talking to a nice
conversation and you see more than you
know is the territorial thing funny that
you say because the other thing like it
was like switched around oh really yeah
and i was like oh like i'm just like
talking to my friends and they're like
and he was like
friends i'm like yeah like friends like
they're not your friends
if if if a guy if a guy and a girl are
in a relationship right can can the girl
have guy friends and can the boy has
do you think like men can really be
friends with women at this point
i'm sorry i i had to just throw it out
to throw that out
otherwise but now like i just changed i
think okay i think most of the time no
but there are a few exceptions
family friends
i think like if you grew up together you
can have genuine friendships i think
growing up together can lead into that
religion you know into those it can yeah
but but i think like there are genuine
friendships where you grew up together i
think there are genuine friendships
where
like sometimes people just live by each
other and like they just become friends
that way yeah like like next one i
become things yeah like or they're in
the same
like friend group i think those are the
three ways where genuine friends happen
like maybe like the sexuality or it's
not
you're not the preference so let's say i
don't want to say like the time like gay
best friend because that's kind of weird
but like if someone's like not your
preference and you're best friends
but you've put them in a friend zone
they usually still might want you so the
question still exists can they still be
friends because you don't want to be
friend but he doesn't want to be a
friend
i don't understand but then i think okay
if that was the case though i don't
think that so like we wouldn't know that
would be the case and then so then we
won't pick up on that we wouldn't push
that and so like would it be would it
really be our fault if like we're still
we considered like naive to him yeah
really
a moment ago we just agreed that women
had better pick up signals and they both
gonna tell me that you can have a guy
for not know he's interacted to you but
i would say like expect first of all i
would say like when you kind of like
categorize that like person as like a
friend then you say that you don't see
any other signal i understand that you
criticize him as a friend but you still
know that he wants more than oh if i
knew
even even
you know you you've never had a
girlfriend that you don't like to
i feel like a lot of girlfriends choose
like attractive friends or like they'll
only be friends with attractive women if
they're going to be friends with them so
that's why i'm really like because they
want you that's why i'm like
yeah so this is why i'm suspicious of
guy friends like both ways like i'm
watching out because i i thought it was
innocent but now i see through
i mentioned this like on one of the
podcasts i've been on before i was like
it sucks sometimes like being a woman
like trying to be friends with guys
because you never know when they
secretly just want to [ __ ] you all the
time
but like in the end when that does
happen it just sucks because then like
you see all these things that you've
done with them and they're like okay
actually didn't mean anything because
all you want to do is [ __ ] yeah and it's
kind of lousy because they went all this
way like they're playing the long game
playing the longest of games just to
[ __ ] you like that which is
so which is a bad strategy guys that
doesn't work keep that in mind
have you ever had a guy make it at the
friend zone short and sweet
[Applause]
because i didn't reject him because i
wasn't attracted to him i thought he was
very attractive i rejected him because
he he was like
too much of a [ __ ] so
weakness from you
and so and like three and he'd been just
pursuing me for like years at that point
so i was like oh and maybe he actually
like likes me you know what i mean
because it's been like three years okay
that's a long time to talk about longer
i mean it's a long game to play was it
worth it was the whole reputation was
the whole this whole his whole
reputation did live up to the reputation
of being a [ __ ]
nothing happened like that with like no
i mean it ended for um different reasons
but
but that wasn't why like it didn't work
out but
um
yeah i guess that like like but i
rejected him for a different reason it
wasn't because i wasn't attracted to him
okay that's not like your typical male
friend you know what about like men have
you had a female friend that you've
known as a friend and then you've
changed men don't put women in friend
zones
yes no wait yes yes they yes they yes
they do yes they do listen now listen
listen yes they do they just sleep with
them
and you're no longer interested in
having a casual relationship with her
but you're on good terms yeah she's a
favorite she's a friend now isn't she
yeah it's different and she's also
casual sex
no but you're no longer having casual
sex because they're stopped for some
reason and you're still you're still
amicable that's a female friend yeah
that that that and they're kind of close
that happens that that can happen of a
guy but the difference is opposite of
women so you will put a fred guy in her
friendzone without [ __ ] him first
hmm
wait okay uh
so what are the categories that you guys
put women in friends with benefits right
friends benefit like and then like
possible relationship and that's it and
then that's why whoa really
someone that you'd want to have kids
with and then like friends with benefits
and then let's say like wifey like what
is wifey category though what do you
mean how do you get from friends with
benefits to wi-fi
that's all i see right there back on
that so you've never met a girl like you
know you were not attracted to but
you're like oh this is a really cool
girl i want to be her friend like i want
to like you know play basketball with
her like play like you know whatever
or like you know drink some rum
and a blue moon type thing so what first
the first one i'll say to you is this um
you you i think one of you mentioned
because you mentioned earlier on um
but you might you said you said it's
maybes what have you
and someone might speak you might reach
out to them because they may say things
and do things yeah difference what what
difference is this
as as men we're attracted to what we see
right we much up to what they hear
so you could tell sweet last women and
they fall for you even though i tried
you might not be trying to see him he
said the right words and he'll get you
yeah we don't that same thing doesn't
work with us we like what we see women's
fight or flaw
i do love me a good sweet talk
in mind right when you see a woman yeah
we're seeing her in pretty much two
different ways we will give when most
men all men give women attention right
because
you like it actually without giving
attention right
but what would the thing that
when i say all but i think when women
get confused they're confuse
sexual attention
with romantic attention so that's
because you give attention doesn't mean
that we like you just wanna yeah [ __ ]
you but like it's just different to us
want to wife you yeah but how would we
know because let's say how like let's
say you've got tinder a guy will only
swipe on you if he's attracted to you
and you go to your first date like very
quickly how do you know this person's
intent without being pushy that's really
difficult to find out because if a guy
okay it's only interested you sexually
first off the back how do you know if
you're supposed to so i'm going to say
something to you then answer your
question so i'm going to say first say
two is dating is stupid
they think we're stupid oh dating oh
dating isn't it so it serves no purpose
it's it's it's redundant doesn't make
any sense your brand your grandparents
they got married quickly had long race
ships dating doesn't work well then why
aren't you married